but what would Aaron Carter
do you guys I regret to inform you but
Christmas is no longer with us and that
tree Just Can't Take a Hint it can take
a hint of lime and it's vasota but it
can't take a hint solid gold it is the
beginning of 2015 and I'm sure a lot of
you have made resolutions that are
somewhat related to health and fitness
and bettering your physical and mental
lifestyle and I feel like I have some
tips for you that could help you in that
area I have a couple healthy recipes and
a handful of fun exercises that you can
do anywhere traveling if you're at home
if you're on a bus so without further
Ado here are some healthy recipes and
exercises for the better you of 2015
this first recipe is for a lowfat pizza
what you're going to need are tiny pasas
portion control y y' also some tomato
sauce I went for low sodium sodium
control y'all it's 2015 get with it or
get without it then I'm going to use
some shredded mozzarella cheese I go for
the mozzarella with all kinds of
descriptive words like low fat part skim
reduce taste Etc more words equal better
product it's why people on dating
websites with super long profiles are
always such a catch note to yourselves
2015 lastly you're also going to need
some Tostinos pizza
rolls
nice the first thing we're going to do
is take one of our tiny pasas our
beautiful beautiful pea and then we're
going to cut it right in half with a
giant knife see perfect next thing we're
going to do is take our tomato sauce and
spread a little bit on each half of the
tiny tiny PE just spread it around and
then maybe like slap the spoon on it a
little bit cuz that's kind of cathartic
next we're going to take our mozzarella
cheese and we're going to open it and
put a little bit on on each half of our
tiny tiny pasas then we're just going to
touch it to make sure it's safe then
we're going to set our Broiler on hey
girl hey I love when my oven says hi it
means it's ready then you have to push
it on we're going to take our tiny tiny
pasas and place them under the boiler in
the oven because I'm holding a camera I
had to do some exercise to get the oven
open two for one I'll take it yet this
is a BOGO event y'all buy one get one
pea then you just let the P sit in the
oven like five FAS then we're going to
take our Tristina pizza rolls and just
read the instructions on the back of how
to make them turns out it's super
easy you put them on a plate and
then you just put them in the microwave
touch them make sure they're safe and
then they just go in the microwave
couldn't do it that time so I used my
hand instead still work and then you
just set it to the button and then you
be now like bici after time it looks
like our pasas are finally ready the
cheese has melted and everything looks
tiny so we're going to set them aside
while we check on our pizz rolls touch
them make sure they're safe and they're
safe to eat these put the low fat pasas
closest to you and the full fat pizza
rolls a little bit further away when you
dig in only eat the lowfat pasas and
then sniff the pizza rolls at the same
time so it feels like you're getting the
flavors of the pizza roll even though
you got lowfat pasas tiny ones because
you eat with your nose and there we go
lowfat Pizza it tastes great we're
having
fun now on to the next recipe we're
going to make a Savory winter soup for
this you're going to need a saucepan
heated over medium heat you're going to
take some low sodium chicken broth
sodium control seriously 2015 and just
put it into the saucepan and wait for it
to heat up the best part about this is
while I'm waiting for it to heat up I
have have some time to write myself some
inspirational messages I love to tape up
my inspirational messages in a place
that I'll see them all day long just to
remind myself of my
potential yes and it seems like our
broth is fully heated up we're going to
take a bowl and pour the broth from the
saucepan into the bowl and there you
have it delicious low sodium lowfat
winter soup we feel great and fun and
full of potential now on to exercise the
first thing we want to do is make sure
our hair and makeup is completely done
check oh wait a minute I totally
forgot something you guys I forgot my
lip gloss like a fuing idiot once the
lip gloss is on it's time to exercise
the first thing you want to do is
stretch and one of my favorite stretches
I like to call Mom I don't want to be in
this Museum anymore to the front and now
let's do one to the side I don't want to
be in this Museum anymore one more I
don't want to be in the mama and feel it
great now on to the exercises I call
this first exercise slow dropping Tetris
piece just make your body look like a
Tetris piece and then fall to the ground
one more great now on to some cardio I
call this oh my God is my camera's still
filming great and walk away and oh my
God are we double sure great but also
are we triple sure because we're an
idiot and got it this next exercise is
called I'm trying to do that Michael
Jackson dance but I can't so I stretch
and to the other side stretch and one
more to the front and lunge great this
last exercise you're going to need a
chair for and you're just going to sit
in the chair and place your arms behind
your back this is called the daughter
from Taken 2 who is held hostage but her
nose itches and she can't get it except
for her knees use that core and you are
still kidnapped they can't hear you
scream and your nose itches and core and
Liam niss I've been taking core perfect
and you're done you did it do you feel
lighter already because your soul is
gone there you go there are some healthy
recipes and some fun exercises that will
help you start the new year off in a way
I don't
[Music]
know guys I'm going to the UK for a mini
Grace's guide book tour information is
down
below
excuse me